welcome back to government and filter
taste by me Josh Smith and today which
one bite the wean documentaries the
Globo is back BBC three one of the
things that I love about it is this
strong message about celebrating beauty
whatever form it comes in and really
bringing out what's from within and
bringing that to the surface and I want
to know from your perspective in your
own life how has that been for you and
how is your relationship around Beauty
changed yeah that's a really good
question when our first took glow up
there was am I still getting a bit of a
hassle you know people said oh you know
why you fronting this makeup gig you
know what are you are you a serious
documentarian are you a nurse or you
know you're a journalist or are you
hosting reality shows and I'm thinking I
don't I don't really know why I can't do
both and I was quite curious and I could
see that was so talented the kids were
so talented but my own relationship with
makeup and beauty I'm not got closer I
can't even I miss a miracle I've got
mascara run at the minute I can't beat
the glamour state I've been in the last
couple of weeks but I hated the way that
people were quite dismissive and sort of
didn't recognise that makeup is really
important to lots of people I think it
also brings out a lot of our internal
thoughts around beauty as well for you
personally going through your life what
had been some turning point in that
beauty so I was 1920 when I did blood
sweat that's the first time I was on
telly and my skin was a mess and you
know I wasn't I wasn't ever done up I
remember people suddenly having an
opinion you know people that write a
newspaper columns or whatever we'll be
talking about they talk about your looks
they comment on you know the way you
talk did I did I dare
so that's the first time I'm sorry on
board there's loads of people looking at
me and I don't know him and they're
strangers passing judgment and then I
think now I'm 33 I think I do like to
feel the part and I love you know I love
it when I'm having a good skin day if
I'm hormonal I'm like
but I think I recognize the importance
of it I saw it's not you know right
right up there for me because I think
also we can all be judged by that idea
of judging a book by it's cover
yeah which is so reductive like you were
saying like the way you talk or the way
that you act and the way and the those
preconceived judgments that people play
some people yeah I was that been for you
when I first started intently it was a
very middle class middle aged
male-dominated space because I was doing
documentaries and current affairs and so
the idea that I had the audacity to kind
of come in and do things in a totally
different way I think shocked a few
people interestingly I remember very
vividly I was in the Beeb office and
there was an older guy I think I was
wearing ripped jeans whatever and and he
was saying oh he sort of passed he said
something about what I was wearing and I
sort of bit back and then I'm thinking
position of it should have been so
reactive but actually I think they sort
of semi respect you for it because there
again I was thinking back to some of the
press you've got in like the last yeah
and without a shadow of a doubt it's
sexist it's come through these
prehistoric filters about what people
feel like they want to digest as
information used to make me so angry and
it makes me so angry when I seen that
treatment of you in the press and I just
don't know how you've managed it so I
want to see what your perspective on
that spin and how you've dealt with it
because you know the other side you seem
stronger than ever
misogyny is still alive and kicking and
I think lots of people always like me to
like Ross Kemp or Louisa you know they
always say she's the female version of
it's like well I'm not really the female
version of anyone I'm just I'm just may
actually and you know some people really
like me and some people can't bear me
and they'd understand why I'm on the
telly I'm sort of all right with them
sort of past caring what strangers think
of me but I think as long as you know
what you stand for and what your
priorities are and what's important
you know you've been riddled with nerves
and you'd never leave the house if you
placed importance on what every single
person said about you have you learned
to shut that off I wonder if because of
what I do for a living that gives me
real perspective hmm you know I'm
spending so much time in refugee camps
for example or with women on the
frontline in Syria or you know
remarkable individuals in Latin America
that have been through hell and and
faced real struggles and a really
suffering you as I said at the top of
the top of the introduction you are the
queen of documentaries among a lot of
people a lot of love to you and twice of
different people that you brought to the
foreground which is such an admirable
thing you put yourself in such for me
watching oh my gosh she's in such
extreme danger like what have you
learned about your own mental and almost
physical strength in those situations
I'm not a massive wimp
I think people assume that I'm really
brave and I've got you know I'm really
courageous because I go to these quite
hostile environments but Josh actually
I'm such a [ __ ] so much of the time I
am [ __ ] myself when I'm on the
frontline or when I'm sort of not
entirely sure how it's all gonna play
out I do feel sick I think to the pit of
my stomach I think I'll stay so you
voluntarily got on the plane you really
wanted this commission and now you're
here you know could very easily just do
sort of straight entertainment I could
stay in the UK and you know do well paid
gigs and but I don't think I'd feel
fulfilled and that's not to sound sort
of too earnest or to moan of highbrow
but I think I recognize my privilege and
I think all were able to bring stories
to a demographic that don't necessarily
listen to a question time or Newsnight
religiously so and I've only got to be
there a couple of weeks so I go there
for a couple of weeks give these amazing
women a platform and then a couple of
million people hopefully will watch it
and then it's you know oh god I didn't
know that that was an issue I didn't
know that was how things were over there
and then they can form their own
conclusions
that's the idea is there like a moment
or a person or someone's story that has
stayed with you and possibly shaped you
the most I mean there must be so many
but is that what really changed she was
a person the Yazidi community for
whatever reason really do have a special
place in my heart so I don't know how
much you know but I in 2014 I didn't
know any of this but 2014 Isis targeted
them specifically and I mean it was like
apparently you know it was barbaric you
know systematically raped the women and
killed them it was you know the stuff
nightmares are made of and the girls
were still so despite being taught you
know the control of that it was still so
soft still really girly dignified really
progressive tactile just wicked just
wicked and I love them and I often think
of them and the best so many I mean it
go in them on door estimate going on
Doris years ago hired a and then she was
in a relationship and you know domestic
violence was a real issue and he would
just treat her really appalling Lee and
one day she said sharp had enough and
I'm not doing this anymore I'm out and
he said well you know you can't walk out
if you don't got any legs and he machete
both her legs off this girl Hema shade
her legs off and she survives in front
of the kids
and she survives and then like weeks
later
she was sat there with an NGO and she
was talking to us and she was offering
offering us so much information because
you know she was sick of people not
being held to account and the justice
system being against and I just
fortunate I how do you meet you have
these women and I and I think again
that's that's perhaps why I don't get
too bogged down with the noise and the
nonsense at home because I think there's
people going through this kind of thing
my first bucket I think they're amazing
I think they're so so cool what do you
learn about the power of listening
because I think that's such a special
and almost rare
scale because we spend so much time
talking and it's all about let's get
talking right now which is obviously
such a positive thing but also listening
is so almost more important in my
opinion I think anyway well I mean that
about the power of listening through
doing what you've done
I mean interestingly I was met in a film
in the prison in Iowa a couple of months
ago with lifers and I went in there and
I was listening to all the women and
listening to their stories and listening
to what they've done and some of the
crimes I think was born out of
circumstance it's circumstantial but
others I mean just seemingly they they
were they were quite evil and there was
one woman who had slip missus all quite
morbid but she'd slit both the kids
throats and I sat and listened for about
15 minutes and I thought you know what
and we didn't end up including her
actually interviewing her because I
thought I just can't be totally
objective and I can yeah so yeah she
didn't end up in the film even though
the crime was so shocking and yeah yeah
it's almost alyssum you know day it's
not how you argue this how you respond
to the person you dishonor we've been
listening just listening like you know
it's tempting isn't it to dig your heels
in it and it's good to stand up for what
you believe in him for what you think is
right but also you know they might they
might have a valid coin I think when you
can come out those experiences and say
so mentally strong is such a special and
amazing Wow but what do you think and
how do you think your relationship your
mental strength has changed from
possibly when you were like nineteen bus
going on disaster now how is it changed
people always say to me have you had
therapy you know do you speak to someone
after all of these trips and I haven't
actually I've been off the date a couple
of times but I haven't kind of objected
it because I'm this fierce strong woman
and I can have this I actually you know
if I needed to speak to anyone I think I
think it's really brave when when you
when you say actually I need a bit of
help giving everything you've done and
all you've achieved if you are on a zoom
call
right now with the 19 year old you oh my
lord
yeah he was just about to go out and do
that documentary your first documentary
on BBC what would you say to her
I would say don't listen to don't place
too much emphasis on what strangers are
gonna think of you and just be honest
about what you're seeing and what you
believe and what you think don't be
afraid to offer opinion but listen and
enjoy it well Stacey I think you are so
special oh my god so nice being to you
like one of my heroines